combattre leur violence documentaire
réalisé par Florie Martin qui a donc
suivi dans le huis clos d'un service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation vous venez de le voir le
travail d'un groupe de parole destiné
aux auteurs de violences conjugales il
s'agit entre autres de les
responsabiliser et bien sûr d'éviter les
récidives ou en sommes-nous concernant
ce sujet tabou de la prise en charge des
auteurs de violences conjugales dans
notre pays et bien nous allons en
débattre maintenant sur ce plateau de
débat Docs en compagnie de nos invités
Mathieu Palin pour commencer bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste et romancier vous
êtes l'auteur de la série des hommes
violents qui a été diffusé chez le
confrère de France Culture en 2019 c'est
une enquête que vous avez prolongée et
approfondi pour écrire ce livre nos
perles nos frères nos amis dans la tête
des hommes violents un ouvrage
disponible aux éditions Les Arènes vous
avez vécu vous êtes immergé dans ces
groupes de parole notamment et on va
bien sûr en reparler avec vous dans un
instant Aline de rolao est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
psychologue clinicienne vous êtes
spécialisé de longue date maintenant
dans ce domaine des violences conjugales
et intrafamilales vous exercez entre
autres au sein du centre de prise en
charge des auteurs de violences
conjugales
d'Île-de-France c'est le CPCA
d'Île-de-France au passage je précise
qu'il existe actuellement 30 c'est PCA
en France dont 5 dans les outre-mer
chaque région dispose de deux ou trois
de ces centres certains départements
n'en disposent en revanche pas du tout
aujourd'hui et un peu plus de 6000
auteurs d'agression et de violences
conjugales ont été accueillies dans ces
centres qui ont été mis en place il y a
très peu de temps finalement c'était en
2019 à la suite du Grenelle consacré
justement
aux violences
conjugales pour commencer je vous
propose de revoir encore quelques
chiffres qui sont apparus dès le début
du film que nous venons de voir ensemble
en 2020 en France 17 600 hommes ont été
condamnés pour violence conjugales on
rappelle tout de même que c'est vous qui
citez ce chiffre dans votre livre il y a
environ entre 210 et 220 000 femmes
victimes de violence conjugales par an
en France et là on parle de chiffres
concernant des plaintes déposées par ces
femmes violentées on mesure à quel point
bien la différence est importante entre
le nombre d'hommes condamnés et les
plaintes déposées lorsque les femmes
osent porter plainte et puis regardez ce
chiffre au moins 80% d'entre eux de ces
auteurs ni l'effet qui leur sont
reprochés et enfin 40% de ces hommes
récidive on va s'attarder un tout petit
peu sur ces 80% d'hommes violents qui ni
l'effet qui leur sont reprochés à
l'occasion de ces groupes de travail
notamment comme on l'a vu dans ce
documentaire c'est vrai que ce qui
ressort pour l'essentiel c'est justement
ça c'est le déni il ne reconnaissent pas
leur responsabilité dans leurs actes
c'est toujours la faute de l'autre et
cela on a beau prendre le sujet par tous
les bouts c'est ce qui ressort en
priorité lorsqu'on parle des hommes
violents pourquoi
pourquoi c'est c'est un préalable déjà à
la dans la prise de parole c'est d'abord
de dire je ne suis pas violent je suis
quelqu'un de bien et le déni moi j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps avec des hommes
violents dans des groupes un peu comme
on vient de le voir dans le documentaire
mais j'en ai accompagné aussi plusieurs
sur le long terme en individuel et le
déni il est à la base de la discussion
je crois personnellement aussi que il
est un peu comme une colonne vertébrale
qui tient l'ensemble et le jour où se
déni s'effondre il y a la personne peut
s'effondrer aussi et
il est lié aussi peut-être à une
évolution de la norme qui faisait que il
y a pas longtemps c'est à dire il une
quarantaine d'années
la violence conjugale était beaucoup
plus acceptée elle était beaucoup plus
normale la violence d'ailleurs
corporelle dans la société aussi à
l'école la violence sur les enfants
était beaucoup plus accepté et on avait
des hommes parce que je déteste dans mon
livre qui éprouvait dire dans des
micro-trottoirs à la télévision oui je
frappe ma femme j'avais pu si jamais
elle sait pas pourquoi si moi je sais
pas pourquoi je la frappe elle au moins
elle le sait c'est et puis oui je la
frappe et puis après comme ça elle me
fera mieux l'amour bon toutes ces choses
qui sont totalement inaudibles
aujourd'hui étaient prononcé en toute
détente il y a encore quelques dizaines
d'années et derrière le déni qu'on
entend beaucoup de ces hommes donc on
voit dans le documentaire ou dans tous
ces groupes de parole qu'on qu'on
fleurit un peu partout il y a aussi mine
de rien une honte à dire oui c'est vrai
j'ai frappé ma femme la femme de mes
enfants et à pas se reconnaître du tout
dans cette figure d'hommes violents on
n'a jamais violent pas juste bousculer
on n'est pas violent elle m'a poussé à
bout je suis pas violent parce que elle
aussi elle a été violente elle a été
violente avec les mots donc il y a une
sorte de de voilà il y a toujours des
périphrases qui permettent de pas dire
oui c'est vrai je l'ai fait et j'en ai
honte et j'aimerais me soigner alors la
psychologue que vous êtes et qui a aussi
travaillé à l'occasion dans ces groupes
de travail et organiser ces groupes de
parole
quelle réponse vous pouvez vous apporter
à face à ces déni est-ce que c'est ça le
noeud du problème lorsque vous êtes face
à ces hommes violents c'est leur faire
comprendre qu'ils sont bel et bien
les auteurs de leurs actes alors c'est
le but de ces stages pour autant il me
semble que tous ne sont pas dans le déni
certains ne le sont pas en fait et après
faut il faut qu'on puisse comprendre
qu'est-ce que veut dire ce déni en fait
puisque la grande majorité
ne savent pas que pousser c'est violent
ne savent pas que
donner une claque à quelqu'un c'est pas
grave en fait
bah si c'est grave
et voilà donc le curseur de la violence
il est très souvent absolument pas le
même que que la loi finalement donc il y
a tout ce travail là déjà ça c'est une
violence ça c'en est pas et découvertes
dans ce film cette notion de violence ou
elle commence ou est-ce qu'elle s'arrête
dans dans le contexte dans lequel peut
évoluer comment je peux dire que je suis
violence si ce que je fais pour moi ce
n'est pas violent
et ça est-ce que c'est du déni en fait
voilà c'est une question après
effectivement
ils sont toujours attaqués ils sont
toujours en réponse en tout cas c'est la
majorité qui enfin qui s'exprime comme
ça si j'ai été violent c'est en réponse
c'est parce qu'il est folle c'est parce
que voilà
et ce qu'il faut entendre derrière c'est
qu'il y a effectivement un sentiment
d'être attaqué par l'autre justifier ou
pas la vérité ou pas c'est une question
de perception de perception et je pense
que c'est ça qu'il faut entendre aussi
et tant qu'on n'a pas entendu ça on va
pas pouvoir passer à oui j'ai été
violent
il y a quelque chose qui a l'air assez
efficace en tout cas au regard du film
que nous venons de voir sont les jeux de
rôle organisés vous avez vécu ces mêmes
expériences vous mettez vous aussi en
place ce type de jeu de rôle alors pour
justement cette prise de conscience de
de la responsabilité face à l'acte
complètement on a on a un jeu de rôle
qui alors sur espérer un l'association
ou je travaille on a un jeu de rôle qui
est tiré un petit peu de la justice
restaurative qu'on utilise aussi dans
les dans les groupes de violences
intrafamiliales parce que c'est très
souvent lié violence conjugale
intrafamiliale et on va mettre l'autre à
la place de l'autre alors qu'on va
échanger
nos places et ensuite on va prendre les
places de la victime de notre voisin
voilà on n'est pas dans une justice
restaurative de victimes avec auteur
mais on va les mettre à la place de la
victime et on va aller complètement dans
le sens de je suis victime même si je
suis auteur et c'est bien par là qu'ils
vont souvent
avoir un déclic et se rendre compte de à
travers eux-mêmes de ce que l'autre
ressent
parce que les émotions de l'autre voilà
c'est souvent très compliqué de pouvoir
les penser de pouvoir les les ressentir
surtout si je me sens attaqué mais si je
me mets à la place de l'autre en restant
quand même moi-même je vais pouvoir
percevoir ce que moi je ressens et donc
ce que l'autre ressent ce qu'on ressent
aussi dans ce film mais vous le dites
dans votre livre on ne n'est pas violent
personne ne naît violent on le devient
et on le devient à cause peut-être d'un
contexte familial de de certains
traumatismes violents aussi vécu lors de
son enfance c'est aussi le témoignage
qu'on a entendu dans la bouche de ces
hommes j'imagine que vous les avez aussi
entendu lorsque vous les avez côtoyé oui
c'est très fréquent d'entendre des
auteurs raconter des traumatismes
d'enfance qu'il les dépasse qu'il
continue de les hanter la nuit avec des
figures paternelles il y en a beaucoup
moi que j'en ai que qui m'ont raconté
avoir physiquement
marquer un coup d'arrêt la violence de
leur père en se battant avec leur père à
l'âge ou physiquement ils en étaient
capables donc 17-18 ans en se disant
j'ai tué le père je ne serai jamais
comme lui et le jour où il se retrouve
en garde à vue pour avoir répété la
violence qu'ils avaient subi eux-mêmes
enfants ou qu'ils avaient été les
témoins sur leur mère ou sur leur sœur
la première personne à laquelle il pense
c'est à leur père en se disant je
m'étais juré de pas devenir comme lui et
me voilà en garde à vue et me voilà
devant la justice et voilà je reproduis
et me voilà
domicile de pas avoir je peux pas avoir
mes gamins et tout et ça
en effet
vous avez dit que il faut entendre aussi
cette ce sentiment d'être agressé il y a
aussi beaucoup de souffrance et cette
souffrance elle va à l'encontre
peut-être d'un cliché sur les hommes
violents qui serait de dire que s'ils
sont violents c'est parce qu'ils veulent
faire souffrir l'autre manipuler l'autre
et tout les pervers narcissiques ça
existe mais c'est loin d'être la
majorité il y en a beaucoup qui sont
violents non pas malgré eux mais mais
qui souffrent de leur propre violence
qui aimeraient être autrement qui
aimerait vivre comme leurs voisins qui
ne frappent jamais sa femme et ça
on peut pas le comprendre si on regarde
juste les faits si on regarde juste il
l'a poussé il l'a frappé il lui a tiré
les cheveux comme on l'a entendu mais il
faut regarder aussi d'où viennent ces
gens on n'a pas si on traçait le profil
psychologique des hommes violents
très souvent on retomberait sur des
hommes qui ont vécu eux aussi des
violences intrafamiliales souvent mais
pas uniquement sur les hommes violents
en fait on voit sur les questions de
délinquance et de criminalité que quand
on ouvre les dossiers dans un tribunal
aux assises ou dans un tribunal
correctionnel on a très souvent des
histoires tragiques dont les auteurs
portent les traces sur leurs épaules
parfois de manière totalement vraiment
inconsciente donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve énormément mais c'est
vrai que la violence est un comportement
qu'on apprend en y étant exposé
c'est un enfant qui grandit dans un
quartier extrêmement difficile avec des
grands frères qui lui apprennent tous
les jours que si il apprend pas à se
battre il apprend pas à se défendre dans
la vie il va se faire marcher dessus il
a un rapport à la violence et à l'autre
et à comment l'utiliser cette violence
pour asseoir sa supériorité ou
uniquement demander le respect qui est
pas exactement le même que dans une
famille dans lequel on apprend à parler
à se mettre à table à régler un conflit
et
ça explique pas tout bien entendu il y a
des hommes violents aussi qui ont grandi
dans des familles dans lesquelles la
violence n'était nulle part mais mais
c'est encore une fois par la majorité
pourtant votre collègue psychologue elle
aussi qui officie dans ce groupe de
travail que on a vu dans ce film
elle souhaite se cantonner ou fait
justement pour responsabiliser les
auteurs
et demande à ne peut pas tenir compte de
ce contexte familial de ces violences
qui peuvent effectivement vous l'avez
dit
influer pour beaucoup sur la violence de
ces hommes
quel est votre position sur le sujet il
faut prendre en compte le contexte
du passé des individus des violences
qu'ils ont pu subir de la reproduction
pour pour ce type de thérapie ou pas
alors moi je pense que c'est stratégique
ce qu'elle a dit ou effectivement il ne
faudrait pas que cela vienne prendre
toute la place
et et dans des excuses
mais je pense vraiment personnellement
qu'il y a une transmission familiale et
on est tous là-dedans vous moi
on a tous des choses de nos parents de
nos arrières parents et la violence et
et un des symptômes qui se transmet en
fait et je
moi je voudrais ins sur la prise en
charge actuelle qui commence à se mettre
en place des enfants victimes de
violences conjugales parce que les
auteurs d'aujourd'hui la grande majorité
c'est les enfants d'hier qui ont été
victimes témoin de violence conjugales
donc je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire
l'économie
de dire oui à ce moment-là il y a eu une
place où effectivement vous avez subi
sauf que maintenant vous êtes auteur et
on ne peut pas cautionner ça faut pas
que ça devienne une excuse
voilà mais je pense qu'il faut
l'entendre sinon la personne va être
enfin on est complètement cristallisé
dans cet épisode traumatique infantile
et et si on le reconnaît pas on va pas
pouvoir le dépasser en fait
voilà sans tomber dans une
psychothérapie individuelle c'est pas ça
dont il s'agit la prise en charge d'un
violon est-ce que c'est un sujet encore
tabou l'a mis en place des centres que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la trentaine
des centres et vous travaillez dans l'un
d'entre eux en Île-de-France est assez
récent en 2019 c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui était mis en place sous le
mandat présidentiel précédent on peut
encore parler d'un sujet tabou les de
moins en moins mais quand j'ai commencé
à travailler sur en suivant un premier
groupe à Lyon
c'était j'entendais encore
d'ailleurs à l'époque c'était la
ministre en charge de l'égalité des
droits et des entre les hommes et les
femmes qui disaient je vais quand même
pas mettre de l'argent sur les hommes
alors que alors que j'ai des
associations féministes qui me
reprochent de pas faire assez pour les
femmes et cette vision là je pense
qu'elle est quand même de moins en moins
partagée une vision assez binaire et
presque maniquée en disant que il y a
les coupables et les victimes on va
vraiment s'occuper des victimes et les
coupables on va les mettre en prison on
va les sauf que la prison ça reste rien
en fait la prison malheureusement
en plus en général des cours tout des
peines assez moyennes vous mettez
quelqu'un dans une cellule de maison
d'arrêt qui est en plus surpeuplée dans
lequel il est difficile d'avoir accès au
travail et une psychothérapie en fait
vous mettez de la poussière sous le
tapis mais vous si cette parenthèse
reste une parenthèse vie il se passe
rien donc ces groupes de paroles c'est
pas non plus la solution dans le sens où
on peut pas décemment penser que en
mettant des gens dans des groupes de
paroles qui pour certains de ces groupes
durent parfois quelques jours seulement
et pas des mois on va pas résoudre le
problème comme ça mais on plante
quelques graines qui chez certains
peuvent germer ensuite parce que c'est
des groupes de parole qui peuvent créer
des réflexions des prises de conscience
et une volonté de changer aussi parce
que
il y a pas de recette tous les hommes
sont un peu différent ils ont des vécu
aussi différents mais il y en a qui
peuvent prendre conscience et commencer
à se déplacer
on est pas en avance malgré tout le
Canada dans les années 80 avait déjà mis
en place ce type d'approche concernant
les hommes violents plus récemment c'est
la Suède qui propose là des
thérapies qui s'allonge parfois jusqu'à
63 semaines donc là on a uniquement sur
sur trois mois dans le film que nous
venons de voir on a pris beaucoup
beaucoup de retard en la matière est-ce
que pour vous c'est tout de même
combattre la racine du mal la racine du
mal des des violences
conjugales et des violences
majoritairement aux femmes dans notre
pays je pense vraiment que si on veut
aider les femmes victimes de violences
conjugale où les hommes victimes de
violences conjugales
il faut effectivement prendre le
phénomène dans sa globalité et pas
seulement une partie
et ces groupes là ils n'ont pas
principalement vocation thérapeutique
on est dans Du Pré thérapeutique on est
dans quelque chose où on va générer on
va tenter de générer un déclic pour une
prison charge par la suite donc
individuel individuel ou groupale il y a
aussi en fait il y a plusieurs types de
groupes de
groupes de responsabilisés de
responsabilisation de groupes de parole
de groupes thérapeutique
de parole et on peut on peut en faire un
après l'autre mais là c'est vraiment on
est vraiment sur quelque chose où on va
essayer de créer un déclic effectivement
de planter une petite graine pour
qu'elle pousse et on espère vraiment
qu'elle pousse et on met tous les moyens
pour autrement dit ce qui est dit à la
fin du documentaire c'est à dire que il
faut une prise en charge
plus spécialisée qui aille plus de là
pour obtenir des résultat espérer des
non récidives puisque c'est ça
l'objectif final
et je pense que le groupe est très
adapté dans le cadre des violences
conjugales parce que il y a
effectivement cette image sociale qui
est compliquée et que et et chacun
autour de la table n'est pas avancé au
même niveau et du coup ils vont pouvoir
s'identifier entre eux et et ces groupes
ont aussi pour vocation d'apporter des
solutions parce que ok on m'a enseigné
j'ai acquis j'ai été conditionné il y a
un problème
ben la solution du problème c'est la
violence mais si j'ai pas d'autre outils
dans ma boîte à outils qu'est-ce que je
fais donc ces groupes là c'est aussi un
moyen de leur donner d'autres outils
pour pouvoir éviter
le recours à la violence en fait mais tu
peux aller un objet de se poser la
question centrale c'est aussi la
question qu'on se pose dans cette dans
cette émission quid de la récidive et ce
qu'on peut espérer faire baisser le taux
de récidive qui est environ de 40 % on a
vu ce chiffre tout à l'heure sur notre
panneau en France en Belgique ça
semble-t-il réussi on a fait baisser le
taux de récidive d'après les données
dont vous disposez on peut espérer
baisser le taux de récidive avec ce type
d'approche aujourd'hui peut espérer
parce qu'on faisait pas grand chose il y
a pas longtemps et on commence à mettre
des choses en place donc on peut
l'espérer on a peut-être pas assez de
recul encore c'est difficile en fait
parce que tous ces chiffres sont sur les
questions de violence conjugales un peu
floues parce que la personne peut
récidiver et la victime n'est pas porter
plainte et ça on le saura jamais donc il
y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de flou
autour de ces chiffres ce qu'on peut se
dire c'est que on commence à mettre des
choses en place et on est aussi dans un
bain d'influence qui est post me to on
va dire avec
des réflexions des débats dans le dans
les médias dans le débat public qui qui
font légèrement bouger les mentalités en
tout cas qui permettent aux hommes aussi
de se poser la question de savoir
comment elles se sont construits
qu'elles sont leurs modèles pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils agissent comme ça dans
leur masculinité sur leur domination
aussi leur domination parce que on est
c'est quand même ça la violence la
domination c'est déjà de la violence et
il y a beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes qui se
sentent pas concernés par ce sujet et
qui peut-être
sont dans un schéma tout bête de
répétition de ce qu'ils ont connu à la
maison c'est à dire un rapport
extrêmement déséquilibré entre un père
qui domine une mère qui fait tout à la
maison et c'est comme ça et puis c'est
le chef de famille on répète ce schéma
donc il y a un contexte aussi qui permet
aux mentalités d'un peu d'évoluer mais
ça suffit pas on voit à quel point dans
les écoles primaires maternelles
primaires on a on a une une vision entre
les garçons et les filles qui est déjà
extrêmement genre et qui permet déjà au
petit garçon de s'affirmer de prendre le
dessus de de d'utiliser déjà la violence
pour comme un moyen de de se faire
respecter et là-dessus on a des cartes à
jouer aussi et dans le centre de prise
en charge des auteurs de violences
conjugales en Île-de-France dans lequel
vous travaillez vous vous pouvez
observer des avancées des évolutions
concernant le comportement de ces hommes
et qui laisse entendre que il ne
repasseront pas à l'acte alors
le CPCA
Île-de-France il est il est
[Musique]
il s'est construit depuis deux ans
donc pas assez de recul pour autant
espérer enfin là où je travaille moi je
fais des groupes depuis 2006 en fait
donc ça fait 17 ans
et en 17 ans je alors c'est que une
petite expérience puisque on a été sur
notre expérimentale au départ
ce qu'on constate à notre échelle
c'est qu'il y a très peu de récidives en
fait quand on a passé ces groupes et
quand la poursuite d'une prise en charge
soit se poursuit après on a très peu de
récidive
alors ça arrive mais très peu
mais ce sera le mot de la fin merci
vraiment à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débattre je citer juste
un dernier chiffre en 2022 l'année
dernière 147 femmes sont mortes en
raison de leur genre à la suite de
violence conjugales et depuis le 7 mai
dernier déjà 41 femmes sont mortes sous
les coups de leur conjoint vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter merci à Selma Sally qui m'a aidé
à préparer cette émission comme à
l'accoutumée et je vous retrouve tout
simplement pour un prochain lebadoc ça
sera bien sûr avec son documentaire et
son débat très bientôt
[Musique]